>>> NEW TONIGHT THE PROVOCATIVE
SHOW OF FORCE IN PUTIN'S FIRST
TRIP OUTSIDE THE FORMER SOVIET
UNION SINCE HE INVADED UKRAINE
TRAVELING TO TEHRAN WHERE HE MET
WITH THE PRESIDENTS OF IRAN AND
TURKEY EVEN, LOOK AT THIS,
HOLDING HANDS WITH THEM.
AND IRAN ROLLED OUT THE RED
CARPET, LITERALLY TO WELCOME
PUTIN WHEN HE ARRIVED AT THE
AIRPORT THIS IS JUST DAYS AFTER
THE WHITE HOUSE SAYS IT EXPECTS
IRAN TO GIVE RUSSIA HUNDREDS OF
DRONES TO USE AGAINST UKRAINE
AND THAT RUSSIAN OFFICIALS
VISITED IRAN TO LOOK AT THEM.
SENIOR NATIONAL SECURITY
CORRESPONDENT ALEX MARQUAARD.
THIS VISIBLE HAND HOLDING, YOU
KNOW, REPLACING THE BIG TABLE
AND THESE MEETINGS.
>> Reporter: ERIN, YOU ARE
RIGHT.
PRESIDENT PUTIN NOT GETTING OUT
OF RUSSIA MUCH THESE DAYS.
HIS SECOND TRIP SINCE HE
LAUNCHED HIS WAR ON UKRAINE IN
EARLY FEBRUARY, A TRIP THE U.S.
SAYS IS DRIVEN BY THE ISOLATION
AND DESPERATION THAT RUSSIA IS
FEELING THESE DAYS, THEY'RE
FACING ENORMOUS ECONOMIC AND
POLITICAL PRESSURE THEY'VE BEEN
ISOLATED BY THE WEST AND THEY
ARE TURNING TO IRAN, ANOTHER
COUNTRY THAT HAS BEEN ISOLATED
BY THE WEST.
WHEN YOU HEAR WHAT THE LEADER
SAID, AYATOLLAH KHAMENEI,
TALKING ABOUT HOW NATO IS
DANGEROUS AND RUSSIA HAD NO
CHOICE BUT TO ACT IN UKRAINE AND
YOU ARE SEEING AN EXAMPLE THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION SAYS OF
THAT DESPERATION IN THE DRONE
DEAL.
RUSSIA EXPECTED TO STRIKE A DEAL
AND BUY HUNDREDS OF IRANIAN
DRONES.
A SPOKESMAN, JOHN KIRBY, SAYING
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE YET THAT
THE SALE HAS HAPPENED OR THAT
TRAINING HAS HAPPENED BUT THEY
DO BELIEVE RUSSIA HAS TO BUY
THESE DRONES BECAUSE THEY HAVE
SUFFERED SO MANY LOSSES
MILITARILY IN UKRAINE AND THEY
ARE FACING ENORMOUS ECONOMIC
PRESSURE, AND SO THEY NEED IRAN
TO REPLENISH THEIR MILITARY
STOCKPILE.
ERIN?
>> SO WE ALSO, ALEX, HEARD A NEW
WARNING FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
ABOUT PUTIN'S INVASION OF
UKRAINE AND WHAT IS COMING NEXT.
HERE IT IS.
>> WE ARE SEEING AMPLE EVIDENCE
RUSSIA INTENDS TO ANNEX
ADDITIONAL UKRAINIAN TERRITORY.
RUSSIA IS BEGINNING TO ROLL OUT
A VERSION OF WHAT YOU COULD CALL
AN ANNEXATION PLAYBOOK VERY
SIMILAR TO THE ONE WE SAW IN
2014.
>> SIMILAR TO THE ONE IN 2014
BUT PRESUMABLY BY SAYING THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MORE THAN
THE DONBAS.
WHAT DOES THE INTEL SAY, ALEX,
ABOUT WHAT PUTIN IS LOOKING AT
IN TERMS OF ANNEXATION?
>> Reporter: THAT AMPLE EVIDENCE
SHOWS RUSSIA WANTS TO ANNEX FOUR
DIFFERENT REGIONS IN EASTERN AND
SOUTHERN UKRAINE, THE DONBAS YOU
MENTIONED.
THAT IS COMPRISED OF LUHANSK AND
DONETSK.
THEY HAD BREAKAWAY REPUBLICS THE
PAST EIGHT YEARS.
WHEN YOU MOVE FURTHER SOUTH THE
REGIONS OF ZAPORIZHZHIA AND
KHERSON.
THESE ARE THE FOUR REGIONS WHERE
RUSSIA HAS THE MOST CONTROL.
BUT BY NO MEANS TOTAL CONTROL N.
KHERSON, THAT WAS AN AREA TAKEN
EARLY ON BY RUSSIAN FORCES AFTER
THEY INVADED IN FEBRUARY AND
LOCAL OFFICIALS THERE BACKED BY
MOSCOW SAID THEY ARE PREPARING
FOR A REFERENDUM, AND THIS IS
WHAT THE WHITE HOUSE IS SAYING
WE CAN EXPECT, WHAT THEY CALL A
SHAM REFERENDUM MODELED ON WHAT
HAPPENED IN CRIMEA IN 2014.
I WAS ON THE GROUND IN CRIMEA
AND SAW THE REFERENDUM THAT
HAPPENED AFTER RUSSIA INVADED.
IT WAS TOTALLY ILLEGITIMATE VOE,
BUT IT ALLOWED RUSSIA TO BE ABLE
TO SAY, SEE, THESE PEOPLE WANT
TO BE PART OF RUSSIA AND,
THEREFORE, WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
OVER THIS HUGE LAND MASS.
YOU'RE STARTING TO SEE ACCORDING
TO THE WHITE HOUSE RUSSIA
PREPARING THE GROUNDWORK BY
IMPOSING THE USE OF THE RUBLE,
BY INSTALLING PUPPET GOVERNMENTS
AND BY FORCING UKRAINIANS IN
THOSE REGIONS TO APPLY FOR
RUSSIAN CITIZENSHIP.
ERIN?
>> USING BUREAUCRACY AS A CLOAK
OF LEGITIMACY.
ALEX, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I WANT TO GO TO JAMES CLAPPER,
THE FORMER NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE
DIRECTOR UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA
AND RETIRED LIEUTENANT GENERAL
IN THE U.S. AIR FORCE.
GENERAL CLAPPER, I WANT TO START
WITH YOU WITH THIS TRIP TO IRAN.
WHAT MESSAGE IS PUTIN SENDING?
AS ALEX POINTED OUT, THE FIRST
TIME HE LEFT RUSSIA SINCE COVID
WAS TO GO MEET PRESIDENT XI
AFTER THE OLYMPICS, RIGHT?
THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT TRIP FOR
HIM TO MAKE.
WHAT WAS THE MESSAGE?
>> WELL, TO ME, ERIN, THIS IS
AKIN TO MR. ROGERS LOOKING FOR
FRIENDS.
I THINK THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
ASPECT ABOUT THIS WAS WHERE HE
DIDN'T GO AS IN BEIJING.
SO HE HAS TO RESORT TO VISITING
ANOTHER PARIAH STATE FOR A GRIP
AND GRIN PHOTO-OP.
AND I DON'T THINK A WHOLE LOT OF
SUBSTANCE.
>> HMM.
>> I THINK IT DOES REFLECT
PUTIN'S DESIRE TO BE SEEN AS A
LEGITIMATE PLAYER ON THE
INTERNATIONAL STAGE, AND WHEN HE
CAN SIT WITH A FOREIGN HEAD OF
STATE, THAT, I THINK IN HIS
MIND, BURNISHES HIS STATURE.
>> SO WHAT ABOUT THE OTHER THING
WE POINTED OUT, THE HOLDING
HANDS, AND THE REASON THAT IS
SIGNIFICANT IS OBVIOUSLY
THROUGHOUT SO MANY MEETINGS
BEFORE THE UKRAINE INVASION AND
AFTER, PUTIN SAT AT THAT
GIGANTIC TABLE, RIGHT, AND IT
WAS ALMOST A MOCKERY BECAUSE IT
WAS SO ABSURD.
BUT YET TODAY HE DOES SIT AND
HOLD HANDS, RIGHT?
HE'S VERY CLOSE WITH THESE WORLD
LEADERS.
DO YOU SEE ANYTHING IN THAT?
I'M TALKING ABOUT FROM A
PSYCHOLOGICAL PERSPECTIVE,
ANYTHING YOU CAN READ INTO IT?
>> WELL, IT IS AN INTERESTING
DIMENSION FROM THEATRICS OR
IMAGE STANDPOINT THAT HE WOULD
AGREE TO BE THAT CLOSE.
BUT YOU CAN BET THAT THERE WAS
SOME CAREFUL TESTING AND
SCREENING DONE BEFORE EITHER
PARTY WOULD AGREE TO SHAKE HANDS
OR HAVE ANY OF THAT INTIMATE
PROXIMITY.
BUT IT WAS INTERESTING GIVEN THE
LONG TABLE MEETINGS AND ALL OF
THAT THAT HE DECIDED HE NEEDED
TO DO THAT PERHAPS TO INGRATIATE
HIMSELF.
>> "THE FINANCIAL TIMES" IS
REPORTING HOUSE SPEAKER PELOSI
IS POSSIBLY TRAVELING TO TAIWAN
DURING A TOUR OF ASIA NEXT
MONTH, AND CHINA THREATENED A
WAR, ESSENTIALLY, AS A RESPONSE.
A COMMENTATOR FOR "THE GLOBAL
TIMES" RUN BY THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT, TWEETED SOMETHING
THAT STOOD OUT TO ME.
THE TWEET WAS IF SHE REALLY
DARES TO VISIT TAIWAN IT WILL BE
A MAJOR SERIOUS INCIDENT.
SHE WILL BE THE ENEMY THAT
DIVIDES CHINA.
SHE WILL EXPERIENCE A RISKY
VISIT.
SHE WILL ALSO BEAR HISTORICAL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR POSSIBLY
TRIGGERING A MILITARY CONFLICT
IN THE TAIWAN STRAIT.
SO THEY'RE SAYING THIS COULD
TRIGGER AN ACTUAL WAR AND
THREATENING HER PERSON.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
SHOULD SHE STAY AWAY FROM TAIWAN
BECAUSE OF THIS?
DOES THIS RHETORIC MEAN ANYTHING
TO YOU?
>> WELL, NO.
I THINK THIS IS NATURAL CHINESE
REACTION, AND IF THEY CAN SCARE
US OFF WITH RHETORIC, THEY'LL DO
IT.
I THINK IT'S A GOOD THING TO
REMEMBER ABOUT THE THREATENING
RHETORIC OF PUTIN IN THE EARLY
STAGES OF THE INVASION WHEN HE
IMPLIED FAIRLY DIRECTLY THE USE
OF NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
WELL, WE HAVEN'T SEEN THAT
HAPPEN.
I THINK I WOULD VOTE FOR NOT
BEING INTIMIDATED BY STANDARD
CHINESE RHETORIC.
I THINK THE CHINESE, FRANKLY,
ERIN, ARE ON THEIR OWN TIMETABLE
WITH RESPECT TO TAIWAN.
AND I ALSO THINK THAT WHAT THEY
HAVE SEEN HAPPEN IN UKRAINE IS
GOING TO GIVE THEM PAUSE.
>> AN INTERESTING AND POWERFUL
TAKE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, GENERAL
CLAPPER.